how are you fellow midwesterner oh
super good midwest is really taking over
the world
that's good people who sit at four-way
stop signs and go like this no you go
no you go no you go oh i don't do that
okay cool
i'm doing amazing today honestly like i
just got um
some news that i've i had been like
preying on legit like preying on so
um i'm just like i'm feeling a little
extra special today
you should you should i i i heard about
that and
uh when we first got on that's amazing
congratulations
it's like it's like it's that magic
it's those magic moments when stuff
happens that you've been asking for that
are undeniable
that it you can't help but believe in
manifestation you can't help believe but
believe in the power of intention
and uh you know asking for what you want
so like i mean i feel like you've been
in this space for a while
and i just want to say first off hell
yeah congrats
and um what up like tell me about your
tell me about your manifestation
manifestation skills yeah um okay so
like i
fully fully fully have like
believed in that since i found out about
the law of attraction and the secret
like as simple as that the secret like
when i found out about that
um it just changed everything for me it
made sense i feel like for everyone
we are always doing that anyway um
but it's just like a whole different
thing when you hear someone
tell you that it's true and that's all
it took and that's like why
i really do most of what i do is because
like i know that
on like a karmic belief we do believe
that like you do
good and good is gonna come back to you
but it all just hits different when
someone that you admire
says it out loud like it's real and i
mean
i'm i am the epitome what i think is
like
an underdog i've been an underdog this
whole time
and like i speak for those people i
speak for the people who are like
yes exactly and it's like this whole
world
wants you to believe that
miracles don't exist honestly we're
forced we're force-fed that every day to
think that like
there there needs to be like a
mathematic problem
into everything that happens in this
world and it's like yo
at the very end of the day like we are
living
in a place that miracles exist when you
accept it when you honestly believe it
and um to show that you're worthy of it
is i think like the pinnacle of why you
wake up every day it's like
when you're not supposed to when things
aren't going right and you can still
believe
in the magic and that it is going that
way for a reason
and that there is actually chess you
know i like to say like god is playing
chess
you know i say that all the time and
like thinking about
we all know that like we go through
these moments where we think
everything goes wrong and then we look
back on those moments five years later
we're like
oh my god like if that didn't happen
i wouldn't be here and this was all part
of this bigger
picture and it's like if you can just
get
anyone that's in your life to watch you
and be like i will be the martyr for
this
i will totally forever be the martyr of
like
let me show you that miracles exist like
that is all i care about and like
yo talent and skill oh my god i
hate those words perfection ill
i [ __ ] hate it i hate that [ __ ] like
i want to be the pinnacle of someone
that's like
showing that that you you are only in
charge of so much
and that if you prove that you're worthy
for these things they're gonna happen
they're going to happen you know and i
just want to be deserving of that now
also more than anything want to be
you know the person that stands on the
front line and fights for that
how do you prove you're worth it what do
you do discipline
oh my god discipline is so important to
me it has become
probably the most
important attribute that i have learned
because you can always add more
discipline to your life and like
it's so funny because discipline just in
general sounds like
such a boring word you're like
ew discipline what like i want to be
free it's like i have to show that i'm
worthy of getting
what i'm asking for and like i do pray
i've become
very very faithful in the last two years
specifically the last two years i've
become so faithful and i pray
every day and i ask for things like i'm
being selfish
i can't believe how much we have
abused the word selfish i i think that
if you can't be at the top of your list
and you can't help yourself first then
what is your help going to do for anyone
else
like you got to help yourself first you
got to get your [ __ ] right
and then your help becomes meaningful
and you can go out and help people but
if you put everyone else to the top of
your list
it's like you're going to die and you're
going to watch someone else's life
you're going to watch someone else's
life and like dude
you are here to make i say this thing i
say movie every day of my life i say
movie movie movie because i believe that
i
am making my own movie i want to watch
the greatest movie i've ever seen
when i die that's it i want to watch
this amazing movie of my life
and see all these things that i created
out of midair
and like if you don't if you don't just
add this discipline to your life
then you're kind of just unwillfully
asking for things
and like you know something so simple
like yo
i want to live i do want to live we're
just speaking to death i want to live i
want to live a long life i would love to
be
the oldest grandpa in the world and the
coolest grandpa still have green hair
all that i would love to make it to
being an old wrinkly person
you know what i'm saying you can
redefine the 27 club by calling it the
127 club
thank you i have the 27 club all
tattooed on my arm
and like that that's the whole idea
right now new rock star vibe 120
reinventing
reinventing the rockstar i say it every
day it's like reinvent the rockstar